[Music]
and i love your figurines in the
background
oh thank you so everyone you can hear
who's talking right here i'm so excited
because i am joined
by the one and only elena kim porris who
plays chloe on jupiter's legacy before
we jump
into this make sure you watch the whole
season first we're going to be talking
spoilers
and then come back to this interview so
elena first off how are you doing today
i'm better now and i'm meeting you steve
i'm very excited to be here
thank you for taking the time of course
i'm i'm so excited to talk to you i i
just saw from other interviews here and
you have such a
exciting just presence about you and i
was like i gotta talk to this
person and i you know it's interesting
too because you bring so much of that to
your character of chloe here
in jupiter's legacy and i'm wondering
though when you first
dived into this character was there
you know a pressure you felt making sure
you got it right
right out of the gates like because you
know it's from this comic book
it's gonna be a big fandom how did you
feel going into it
well steve um yes there's a big fan base
behind jupiter uh of course there was a
pressure
um that i could tap into because chloe's
under a lot of pressure um in the show
but
of course you know with having a very
passionate fan base you want to
you want to do the role justice you want
to bring it to life in a way that
satisfies people
because i know what i've been saying
it's a lot like when i read stories or
get attached to certain
material you picture the characters in
your mind you know like i feel like
there's an internal movie going on
when i'm reading books so i'm like i get
it and especially when you have
the comics right you've got the
illustrations that are poppy and glossy
you know by the talented frank quietly
so when you've got that already
established it's like
you know you wanna you hope you hope to
do a good job
so um there was that going into it um
but what was lovely was to have the
actors to have
mark you know weighing in and giving
input in it and feedback and stuff as
far as the inspiration behind police
there was a lot to play with and stick
my teeth into
um so i'm hoping people will um you know
like chloe in her journey
and connect with her because she also
kicks butt too hell yeah and
i think what people really like about
chloe is she has such an awesome look
about her she's very fashionable being a
model
so for that was there any inspiration
for you for her look from
other sources of media or tv or movie or
was it mostly from the comics
well the comic plays a big part but
there was a lot of discussion like
first we have this whole element of
carrie fisher inspiring her as a
character
and and what her like you know growing
up with very famous parents and feeling
that pressure
so that element then we've got we had
some edie cedric
like aesthetic vibes going on in the
mood boards i was seeing from wardrobe
which i was all for that um
you know what else i'm trying to think
uh we had uh
we again she's a fashion model so the
the clothes
everything played such a huge part in in
in also putting on like
because she doesn't wear a costume right
she's not about a cape or a suit so
that's kind of her uniform
in a sense into uniform um so the second
i put on that wig just as
as a whole like the wig itself
immediately i felt myself get very
the attitude came out and i'm like oh
i'm walking differently
chloe is you know she's she is appearing
she is among us
um but another aspect just because i'm i
can't help but say it because i'm a very
proud
girl because you don't know this steve i
i couldn't help but draw parallels to
also greek mythology and equating the
characters
what would that what would her because
these characters
these superheroes are almost like you
know they're walking amongst these
mortals some have power some don't
so in looking at the gods and goddesses
who would she be in that realm and i
kind of feel like she's an artemis
you know the she's independent
an independent spirit doesn't want to be
constrained to the status quo and what i
expect is what's expected of women
um and then i feel like her brother is a
bit of apollo and icarus
so there's some parallels that you've
got dad there's a bit of zeus
so i could go on there was a lot to play
with because she is such a complex
intricate character
uh to play yeah no and naming all those
things that like you see inspiration for
for this character and you bring to the
screen so well
did you find though any of uh elena
herself
in chloe well steve
i i want to know of course if you if you
found any of yourself and chloe because
that's what i hope for i know personally
i um i i felt like okay she's very
temperamental right
and she reacts in big ways because she's
such a passionate sensitive sensitive
she's almost like the most one of the
most human of the bunch you know
she's so deeply intertwined with her
emotions and what she feels
so her impulsivity and her kind of
inability to
sometimes make rational decisions like
she's very impulsive i did connect to
that sometimes
you know i try to like control that um
so i kind of got to let it go
like let it rip on when shooting this
like just just
unleash um but there's many aspects also
you know
she has a big sense of loyalty and even
though on face value
like no she doesn't she's not even
fighting with her family
in the union but it's that's what's
making her
be in this this painful place we meet
her in is because she knows not being a
part of the union is hurting the people
she loves the most
but she just can't do it she's not built
like her father is yes she's headstrong
like him
but she's not she's too real for that
stuff like putting on this persona this
tape
and being like i'm here to save the
world i'm all perfect which she's like i
know people will see through this and
she's just she's not about
she'll know other people will see you as
a fraud but beyond that
she'll feel like one um yeah if that is
no that's that totally answers that's
that's an amazing answer and
yeah it's interesting because she like
you're giving all these emotions and
feelings and thoughts she has and
it really shows well in how interesting
the character chloe is but you also
mentioned her father sheldon here so my
favorite line chloe has in the season
actually is in episode two when she's
actually
you know they're always bickering her
and her father but she says the only way
out of the loop is for me to stop being
me
or you stop being you do you think
chloe truly thinks is the only way for
them to ever really
piece beautiful question steve i'm so
impressed like you're you're just
pulling out all the stuff i had
that's nice and actually i love that
scene um that bagel scene
um between uh myself and josh was
was super fun because it really is the
crux of their
the issue of how they just can't
communicate like they're saying words to
each other but this power struggle of
of their the power like each one trying
to assert their will and what they want
to do chloe trying to just forge her own
path and be comfortable in existing and
being in her own skin and just being
happy
um they've lost the means of of like
they're saying words but no one's really
hearing the other person and when she
says yeah can
we have i have to stop being sipping you
it's
i think it's her just coming to terms
with the fact that she's losing her
father she's lost her
she's out she's lost her father she's
had to come to terms without her entire
life of him being absentee both of her
parents
being too busy saving the world rather
than saving the deteriorating
deteriorating relationship between
herself
and her will her them and their kids so
she's kind of accepting this and
realizing wow
how are we going to go forward i'm she's
crying out in ways she's crying out in
that conversation she's crying out when
she's on billboards
because it's a way of saying like accept
me see me recognize me and i don't even
know if she's fully aware she's doing
that
um so i think a lot of it is like she's
just trying
to get through to him but she's seeing
how kind of futile it is especially in
that moment
um and this is what pushes her to self
to isolate herself emotionally she goes
into drugs and drinking and alcohol
like partying and all this stuff because
it's a means to stifle that
and numb the pain so speaking of that
part of chloe's character that's
more of the darker side here and where
the tragedy kind of
happens where we see in episode four it
really leans into chloe's character
and all the devils are here and i'm
interested in this line chloe responds
to janna saying
brendan can't be him and you can't be
her i don't have friends because i'm an
[ __ ] so this happens right before
your character
overdoses yeah and i'm wondering as an
actress how dark of a place
did you have to get into for a sequence
like this and
in a sense is it scary yeah it was that
scene
no that whole you know that whole
episode was so like there was a lot
leading up to it i was very excited but
i knew like okay the stakes are high
here for
her and especially with her arc and
where i knew she would go in the comics
i'm like okay this is important to
really get it across and where she's at
she's dealing with so many insecurities
severe loneliness depression
abandonment issues trust issues people
where she's feeling like you know
nobody actually wants to know me for who
i am or connect with me on a real level
without getting trying to get to my dad
or the union
so i think she's just at this point
where i mean and then you've got her
brother as well who
probably was the only kid growing up
that she could really relate to because
he was in the exact same boat as her
having parents that weren't there
um but then they drifted apart because
he's just getting you know caught up in
trying to
faithfully follow the dad in this code
which is just it's an impossible kind of
again a futile
pursuit um but i think you know that
there was so much you know and a lot of
research to do
a lot of like also talking to friends of
mine who were generous enough to talk to
you about their struggles with addiction
um and kind of seeing like okay it's how
it matches to where i was approaching
like
where she's trying to hide her pain
where it's all coming from
the neglect she feels the guilt she
feels and the drugs and all of that is
a means to sedate that that those
feelings but it only heightens
everything
more for her it's not an elixir it
doesn't take care of anything
it only you know it it it just kind of
it just worsens everything for her but
it's a lot it's a lot to to
to go into no yeah i mean look you're
you're giving the fans what they want to
hear
really just into this complicated mind
of chloe
insight into it and it's really exciting
to see how much you love playing this
character and how well you know this
character and it shows yeah because at
this point steve she's like
she's like i think what you're getting
at too what you're making me think of is
like she's pretty much like ready to die
in a sense like that's how
she should she's like i don't even care
like she doesn't even care about her
life anymore
at the point where she's like i have
nobody nobody cares about me i'm seen as
a jerk to everyone
when i'm just i'm just being my i'm
trying to keep it real
i can't put up this facade and then she
hates herself because she's on
billboards and modeling and it's like
she's against selling out in the union
yet she's selling out
modeling so it's like pick your poison
pick your cell out so she knows she's
being a hypocrite at the same time
so there's so much she's navigating and
that's what makes her so lovely because
she's so layered she's not just one
thing
you know but she's also strong at the
same time well speaking of that her also
being strong too like i think what's
really exciting is towards the end of
the season when she
comes in has this badass moment where
she rescues hutch and they're in this
like chamber with no oxygen
and there's some really cool you know
stunt work here are you doing your own
stunts because i know there's a fencing
video of you on youtube
and you also had a martial arts training
video on instagram so i'm like
she must be doing this right or was it
actually somebody else doing that
i love martial arts i have a background
in judicial chinese ballet that's what
started my love for chinese culture and
learning mandarin and singing in the
arts
so this was whenever there's a film that
is intertwined with that i get super
excited we learned a lot of like
a different forms of martial arts
including wushu but um we did have a
wonderful stunt team my son double
aleche rosano love
italian girl who she makes me look good
and does like a really intense stuff and
i
i she was actually dur i was shooting in
in australia for majority of the year
working on two projects um one of which
is
stephen king horror but the other one is
actually a sci-fi samurai movie it's on
hiatus right now but we're going to be
continuing at some point but she was
like coaching me
teaching me bojitsu and that was what
that video is it was in preparation
so she teaches me mojitsu virtually and
i sing to an italian as a thanks
i'm like
hey
we became like sisters on this shoot and
she did like she does like the real
intense stuff
yeah because it's a whole but i like to
do what i can because i
i mean it's fun to to kick bud and you
know i've seen we're not actually
real but but you know we're we're flying
we're we're doing all kinds of different
things it was fun to conquer my fear of
heights when we were in the harness you
know doing the flight stuff
um you know there's a lot of different
elements to
the superhero training yeah and that's
interesting you mentioned fear of
heights i have a fear of heights as well
so
proud of you for beating that good for
you
benign paroxysmal positional vertigo you
get like i get dizzy spells nose bleeds
like
it's i've had moments where i was doing
dangerous liaisons on broadway
i literally i had to do a costume change
so quickly and was taking a corset off
like in a quick
quick change i had a nosebleed on stage
the whole scene was dizzy the room was
spinning so it's been a terrifying
nearly debilitating fear of mine but i
overcame it and i believe you can too
steve one of these things
you've got when when everything's
vegetable we gotta get you in a harness
we're gonna get you flying and you will
come back
yes i can do this thank you um
switching gears a bit though i have to
ask uh
talk to me about the sloth family you
have are any of them joining us today
because i noticed on twitter
you shared a picture oh okay which ones
are those
so this is we've got daphne and fiona
here i hugged them to me whenever i'm in
the interviews i can't help but doing
the junket
i just like it's like a i realize i'm
sure i've got like a security blanket
thing but i don't mind it because they
give me an optional support
i've got my i love that blanket too wow
rest of the family then they're all over
the house they're my spirit animals
steve
what about you what's your come on throw
it at me what's your name zebra 100
i got it i have a zebra blanket it's in
the other room right now but i need
i gotta get a zebra family like you got
this whole family where our blade gets
together
at some point we're making a face and
you have to send me a picture
okay i want i want memorabilia okay oh
you know
um my last question to you before i let
you go i'm having such a fun time with
you
uh so i wanna know you you have such a
an amazing personality and everyone
watching this interview who didn't know
you yet and then watching the show are
gonna be like oh my god like this is
amazing so would you ever do some sort
of podcast or youtube type show just
with elena like
talking well maybe if i was doing it
with steve barley like
because i don't know i'm not gonna like
i'm not opposed to anything i'm always
driven by the passion you know if it's
learning language silence singing like
whatever it is like that speaks to my
heart i'll do it and
you know it's who knows i never say
never but i think we'll have to do some
kind of podcast action i hope we get to
meet in person
steve if this goes too quick yeah and
you know what we need to do we need to
commemorate this with a little
screenshot
okay on the count of three we smile and
we say volley
one two three barley
oh shoot i messed that up oh we got good
i got
you covered uh no this was so much fun
um
thank you so much for joining me elena
everybody i mean if you're already here
watching us you've clearly watched super
legacy watch it again
if you haven't watched it watch it it's
on netflix now follow elena on instagram
and twitter she has a great
profile an account to follow it's so
much fun and elena i hope to talk to you
in the future
steve i want to meet you in person one
day and i want you to sign this picture
i have a thing wherever i work on movie
sets i take the seat cover and i have
the
crew the cast sign it like a yearbook
and i also do that with reporters like i
try and take pictures whenever i find
moments and when i meet you you sign it
for me
i will i oh i promise but you got to
sign stuff for me too when they come out
with the little uh
funko pop of you you're gonna sign it
for me okay oh my god i because i
watched your videos and i saw harry and
lloyd and i was like are we gonna see
them today i'm pretty sure that was
harry
that you had i think it was funny
with you i'm sorry there weren't too
many i'm sorry
swenson
oh my god uh pull over no it's a
cardigan but thanks for asking
yes i feel like we would go to town with
these movie quotes
oh hell yeah this is happening we gotta
connect on social media and stuff
never forget the slots have witnessed it
i'll be waiting for the zebra pictures
okay
okay thank you so much elena have a
great rest of your day
lots of love bye-bye steve